previously on TV sins I'll never trust a
man in black the difference is between
you and me I make this look good
two full minutes of credits copying the
mat mechanics of a game called mist what
just because it was 26 years ago you
don't think they copied it icicles
melting totally makes burning an
innocent child at the stake worth it I
know the show's dark but killing off
Stannis's daughter is easily the most
unforgivable action the show has taken
thus far and while technically we're not
covering that episode we are covering
aftermath and this is my youtube channel
so cute game of Thrones you're getting
us in the Lord has shown me Bolton
vanna's burning did he also show you the
Lannister lions lilting the stark sigil
slouching or the Turk Arian towers
trembling I guess logically the Lord of
Light legitimately loves alliterative
literacy the men when they deserted
before dawn how many nearly HOF or maybe
Thanos snapped his fingers in the night
raised his hands and they all stood up
at once tens of thousands of them the
biggest army in the world Oh doctor
PewDiePie this will be like the T series
thing all over again
the dragonglass it wouldn't have
mattered anyway there's been a mountain
of it mountain shadowing how's it feel
to be friends with the most hated man in
Castle black
to be fair pretty sure that was always
the case Jon's just now the most hated
man with more power these to us then
long medicines company toast somehow
makes it into an episode of Game of
Thrones pop dammit that's a lot of food
and timber for you to abandon just to
shave a few seconds off the time it
takes you to get back Dark Phoenix wait
a minute how did this end up in the
woods Stannis and his army were
surrounded in this open field even if
they decided to retreat how did they get
all the way here of all the great
mysteries on Game of Thrones there may
be none greater than how Stannis
Baratheon fought in so many battles
without a helmet and survived always
wear your helmets kids are these
Kingsguard to Renly Baratheon I was
there when he was murdered by a shadow
with your face and now I'm conveniently
here for a convenient chat with you upon
your convenient defeat conveniently I
Brienne of Tarth sentence you to die I
would give every cent back if Henry
Fonda showed up right now and said I
don't think he did it and then Lee Jay
Cobb showed up and said you're crazy old
man I would call it 12 angry Brent's
it's like we're done here what kind of
human doesn't continue to play dead
after hearing your bloodthirsty
attackers say he's on his way out maybe
one that's in a TV show that wants to
let deprave ramsey twirl his moustache
some more this whole area is La Femme
Nikita storyline is about a city a
storyline as the show has ever had and
Sam and Gilly are still on the table
first person on my list you know arias
version of the blacklist is much more
violent than the one on NBC but the fact
that this one doesn't have James Spader
is definitely a sin no one nothing
seeing our little Aria as a straight-up
killer is very unsettling at least this
is as disturbing and awkward as it will
get for our character we met at age 11
right that girl has taken their life the
wrong life a guy who kidnaps underage
girls to have sex with them the
many-faced God has impossible standards
he wants no one discount Criss Angel I
feel like the show needs to at least
give us more rules when all these faces
work I thought they had to be dead to
use their face apparently not if you're
gonna mission impossible me at least do
me the favor of showing a little bit of
practical reasoning new marcella who dis
I wish you all the happiness in the
world oh that's sweet it's nice to see
families put aside their differences for
a common good yeah I'm good good but you
need somehow bronzed character
description in the show's Bible made it
into this episode script I thought you
and mother and hey Marcella just because
you exist doesn't mean you should be Pro
incest okay glad you my father it's
beautiful that this sweet girl might be
the sign of a new age and Thrones we're
G's Thrones come on I even finish the
sentence also glad we could have that
great moment between Uncle father and
daughter nice but why is it the poison
always waits until you've had a major
revelation and Reconciliation in your
life to work forgive me but why would we
bring you have you ever tracked animals
in the wilderness when Thrones is great
it's great but when it's stalling by
spending five full minutes on an all-out
pissing match to decide who's qualified
enough to go look for the Khaleesi it's
not so great you said toughest man with
no balls I haven't met
that's test Achilles Queens closest
confidant commander of the unsullied and
a foreign dwarf for this gown face Game
of Thrones somehow got into my idea
journal and snatched my synopsis for a
game of Thrones spin-off crossover
called CSI marine hello old friend
awesome Varys the CG work on discount
trogdor here is absolutely beautiful
rumor has it that needing the money for
the Dragons is the reason the dire
wolves weren't a larger part of the
story at this point and in honor of Lady
Grey when shaggy-dog and summer I
bequeath these sins
meanwhile Cersei is the new black
confess confess fine I think cargo
shorts are very practical and
underappreciated happy now
see that now what is the statute of
limitations here it took you 15 years to
apologize for gossip nothing then no oh
come on dude she admitted the cousin but
someone like that lie about your brother
to Fishbach high Sparrow I might drop
the mothers mercy roll shimmer shalls'
and present herself as the gods made her
to you I'm sorry but there was zero
chance Cersei had that much hair on her
head they she was born if you're going
to go by the book you need to pay
attention to the specifics shame shame
body shaming [ __ ] shaming change aiming
also I'm not sure why shouting out
michael fassbender movie titles helps
with the tone Minh nem the same one over
and over it just seemed repetitive
[Applause]
the scene has been going on so long I
really feel like the shaming is now
geared toward the viewers how is this
pycelle eyebrow raise not become a more
prevalent animated reaction jiff that's
right I said it's up G jiff just just
the jobs intended oh oh they're FML
sander I didn't hear you X not gonna
you're here at Castle black because well
it had to happen sometime
Jon Snow is an insignificant bastard in
the minds of the Nightwatch betrayed
them in the end he had to die too bad we
won't get to see him find out who his
mom was Ned just left that dangling
there in season one who will never find
out yeah well it happens to the best of
him ah the innocence of children will be
John's saving damn it Thrones HBO tries
to snow us for a whole year with this
cliffhanger and it simply won't work
I haven't seen an ending that will be
more obviously reversed since the snap
sure this was serious but it turned into
something fun if you leave who's left to
give me advice I trust
[Music]
in egypt's land
[Music]
missed it by that much
I'd like to take his his face may I have
the honor of presenting the newest
member of the Kingsguard
I am Locutus of Borg resistance is
futile hewn the princess oh the ball